When the list item is clicked,
use Android's Toast mechanism
to display the weather forecast string.
A Toast is a pop-up that displays
a message for a few seconds
before fading out.
It's particularly useful for debugging,
where it can be used as a way
to indicate status visually
without altering the app UI.
We're going to put our list view,
set item click listener
into forecast fragment
inside of the onCreateView method.
We'll just start typing
listView.setOnItemClickListener
and let the auto complete
fill in the rest.
Inside of this function,
we're going to add click listener,
which we can instantiate in place.
Here's where we can call the code
in Android to display the Toast.
Now that you know
where to place the Toast code,
take a look at the Toast documentation.
Add a Toast when the list item is clicked
that contains the weather information.
Hint. You can get the forecast
by getting an item
from the forecast adapter,
at the position given
by the OnItemClickListener.